so under tony fouch of the us government
has funded horrifying experiments that
torture and kill dogs for no good reason
we've gotten nothing useful in science
from this torture and yet fauci has
spent more than 400 thousand dollars to
trap beagles in mesh cages where they're
bitten to death by flies
so
this is horrifying it should never
happen again how do we prevent dogs from
being murdered
just so tony fauci can spread more money
around to his friends judy mancuso has
been working on this for a long time
she's arguing that lawmakers in
california should create a bill of
rights for cats and dogs she's ceo and
president of social compassion and
legislation we're grateful for her
efforts and happy to welcome her tonight
judy thanks so much for coming on tell
us how you could stop this
well our bill is actually directed
at
people who adopt at shelters so the dog
and cat bill of rights
is a list of specific rights that dogs
and cats should have
that will be posted at shelters humane
societies rescue groups
so that people who are adopting
understand what exactly the expectations
are
in having
an animal
right
would that prevent
do you think the kind of cruelty you're
seeing in these pointless experiments on
animals people are being paid to torture
animals to death there's no evidence
that
human lives are saved because of it
well that would be a completely
different bill and we did work on a bill
that had to do with cosmetics and
personal hygiene products sold in
california that shall not be tested on
animals so
that is something that california did do
we got signed into law
but
your the conversation you're having
about animals and testing is a whole
other one that we would love to address
because it is our taxpayer dollars that
go to animal experiments in universities
across the united states so not only is
it in
universities with our taxpayer dollars
it is public and privately funded and a
lot of these
these experiments have been done before
and they don't need to continue and
there are non-animal tests that have
higher uh efficacy rate that should be
used
so i hope this is the first step toward
doing that your animal bill of rights in
the state of california something good
to come out of california because if you
can mistreat dogs you'll mistreat people
i don't think there's any question about
it well there's a
direct correlation uh that is well
documented of that yes
there certainly is i appreciate it g
mancuso thank you
thank you for having me on
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight